Les Colombes se les
La Colombie est celle qui est celle du monde
larens mon et
Nous entrons dans notre entreprise pour vous aider
notre
v
J'ai le droit de protéger cette histoire
Vous pouvez passer à travers
rre dépres ms je ce jour comm ilis la
rose de la
t
je
Et mon amour
voix
dans
lèvre
un
je suis pour
Mon amour
Et mon amour
Pour son étoile
Une réponse
entrer dans
le rêve
Mais il
Ralentissez pour ne pas
Nous voyons
inspiration
je dors
Mon amour
Je me réveille pour garder
le rêve
Que
être vu
Et l'expulser
Les nuits où
traversé avant
que
Nous rencontrons
Et il a choisi
Nos jours
je veux aussi
Choisissez-moi
Votre réponse
Une table aussi
choisir
pour moi
Votre réponse
Table, dors, oh
Mon amour, dors
Mon cher
Que la voix des mers s'élève
Agenouille-toi et dors
Mon cher
Flamboyant
En toi et sauve
Votre rêve de
fourchette
Un oiseau envieux
Salle de bain, oh mon garçon
Le pigeon est un oiseau
Les pigeons atterrissent
la salle de bain
Quoi
moi
m